you know i have not spoken much recently
on the podcast and the broadcast because
uh about the kyle rittenhouse trial
because we've been covering essentially
the full trial every day on facebook and
um youtube not on twitch because we're
banned from twitch for 30 days so i've
just been getting so much of it i
haven't commented but i do want to talk
about it a little bit today over the
last 24 hours the kyle rittenhouse case
in kenosha wisconsin it's the trial of
kyle rittenhouse who is accused of when
he was 17 last year um homicide against
two individuals that he killed as well
as miscellaneous other charges related
to guns and and other things
this is a trial where the defense has
now taken over the defense called kyle
rittenhouse to the stand as a witness
and the prosecution was able to
cross-examine kyle rittenhouse yesterday
this has now led to a call for a
mistrial by the defense so let's look at
one article about this and then we're
going to look at a video because the
judge flipped out yesterday this is
getting a lot of attention because it
has become quite wacky
um the kyle written house case is now in
jeopardy as lawyers seek a mistrial
trial judge accuses prosecutor of
improper line of questioning
what has taken place is that the
defense has asked for a mistrial on two
bases the first is that at the beginning
of his cross-examination of kyle
rittenhouse the prosecutor
um
sought to
ask kyle rittenhouse
about not
making a comprehensive public statement
about what he believes happened
the judge felt that this was trying to
use written houses silence against him
which would be a violation of the fifth
amendment okay
that's one basis on which the defense
wants a mistrial the other basis on the
defen on which the defense wants a
mistrial is that they say the prosecutor
um questioned rittenhouse about things
which the judge had already said should
not be brought up this is a basic
summary of the reasoning for the
defense's request for a mistrial the
judge is considering that request the
defense wants a mistrial with prejudice
meaning that that's it that the case
can't be restarted a new case can't be
restarted against kyle rittenhouse that
would be
wild if that took place
i also want to play for you video when
this was being discussed of the judge
sort of flipping out on the prosecutor
take a look at this in the questions
i asked the court to strongly admonish
him and the next time it happens i'll be
asking for a mistrial with prejudice
he's an experienced attorney and he
knows better
mr
finger
first of all your honor this was the
subject of emotion i'm well aware of
that
and the court left the door open
for me not for you
well my understanding of you should have
come and asked
for uh for reconsideration you did on
the one motion and in fact i granted
your motion for reconsideration that was
that right i i i'm not talking
excuse me i uh
i did i created we did not move forward
we have not filed any motions to
reconsider in this case that was their
motion for reconsideration which i deny
but
uh i said
i denied it
or i indicated a bias towards denial is
what i did held it open with a bias
towards denial why would you think that
that made it okay for you without any
advance notice to bring this matter
before the jury
you are already you were i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country for 40
years 50 years i have no idea why you
would do something like that so as many
have noticed the judge seems to only
bring this level of energy against the
prosecution there have been a whole
bunch of questions raised about this
judge and listen if the judge is biased
there's going to be the possibility of
an appeal in theory although prosecution
appeals and jury verdicts are very very
tough um i want to just kind of give my
general take on this case at this point
in time because i'm getting a lot of
emails from people saying david you're
this is obviously self-defense david
even tyt now says it will self-defense i
don't know what tyt has said to be clear
i'm just saying people are telling me
that that's what tyt has said let me
make my position on this case very very
clear i believe that kyle written houses
self-defense from a legal perspective is
going to be valid enough plausible
enough in the immediate situation
in which he shot the two people that he
killed
uh that he will be found not guilty i
believe that it is a plausible
i believe it may be quite true
that he feared for his life in that
moment which is what is on trial
okay so i'm not saying any of this uh uh
you know he's obviously guilty it
obviously wasn't self-defense
i think that from a legal standpoint
self-defense is going to be valid enough
based on the facts that not guilty will
be the verdict there
i also
believe that the entire context here is
a disgusting context he had no business
going to kenosha and being armed that
night
the totality of the incident is
nauseating and the fact that
if he's convicted he will be considered
a martyr by the right if he is uh
acquitted he will be made a hero by the
right for the fact that he was there
with a gun
defending himself
when the truth is that this case is
emblematic of everything wrong with
american culture around guns
masculinity
vigilante justice
etcetera etcetera
now you can break down each part and say
well okay
in general just for being a 17 year old
being familiar with guns is not
inherently wrong or immoral
um
in theory protecting property
while holding a gun it's not i mean you
know would we feel differently as a
viewer emailed me if this was someone
protecting a black-owned business with a
gun from kkk
looters or something like that
most progressives would probably say no
that it's okay that that's being done
and if you do this you certainly can
make the case that there's no particular
one smoking gun
but this is
a symptom
of toxic underlying conditions
gun culture
vigilante culture etc
and
that is different than should he be
found guilty that's not a crime what i
just said
so
let's not
misstate each other's beliefs about this
and for the people emailing me saying
david you're so wrong for saying that he
should be found guilty it's for the jury
to decide and i believe that the
evidence for the narrow circumstances at
issue in the case
self-defense is plausible
and that he will be found not guilty on
the homicides that's my belief send me
your thoughts you can find me on twitter
at deepakman
i love growing my own food at home many
of you have seen my gardening stuff on
my instagram i get great tips from the
audience and one of our sponsors is
lettuce grow which is by far the easiest
way to grow your own food at home the
lettuce grow farm stand is a hydroponic
unit that waters and fertilizes itself
you can grow more than 200 varieties of
fruits and veggies at home indoors or
outdoors
i love my lettuce grow farm stand i've
grown edible flowers tomatoes
strawberries eggplant it only requires
five minutes of maintenance a week i can
grow 36 plants at a time it uses 95
less water than traditional gardening no
packaging
no waste i didn't even know it was
possible to grow food like this in a
portable unit but i love it and lettuce
grow is giving you fifty dollars off the
farm stand when you go to letisgrow.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below